Hello Freak bitches.
Maybe they,
they,
the story has been clarified while we've been talking,
but this is now seems that Susan Rice came out at one point.
She said she knew nothing about the unmasking of,
of Trump associates in,
in,
um,
the this reason surveillance case.
And now it seems that she is claiming that she actually asked to have certain
names unmasked and,
and so like this,
this has been seized upon again,
just in the last few hours as exam.
An example of a lie,
right?
Which seems very sinister,
um,
at,
but as though it equalizes the two sides here,
right?
Let's low.
So let's say worst case scenario,
Susan Rice lied about having some knowledge of this investigation.
Um,
that doesn't,
it says something bad about Susan Rice.
It says something.
I mean,
she has to deal with the consequences of that lie,
but it doesn't exonerate all of the line that Trump has done about everything
under the sun.
Right?
So what so destabilizing here is at the moment,
the moment,
and this is even true of honest errors,
the moment that a news organization like yours or the New York Times commits an
honest error that gets pointed to from those who want to treat the mainstream
news media as just fake news as see everything's the same.
Like,
like,
like right.
Like they're,
you're no better than than somebody who's just manufacturing fake news on a
laptop in his basement.
Um,
so it's like,
it's,
and the flip side of that is when Alex Jones get something right,
it seems to,
it seems to make him look like a,
a dignified journalistic enterprise analogous to the New York Times or to ABC
News.
And neither of those things are true.
I mean,
there are small lies and then there are huge lives.
There are honest mistakes but be committed by totally reputable organizations
that are really trying to get the facts straight.
And then there are malicious,
it's just militia,
malicious propaganda outlets that are not at all trying to get their facts
straight.
And I'm trying to engineer everyone's credulity and ignorance into something
that is just purely a matter of,
of,
uh,
you know,
tribal sentiment,
and,
um,
so we lose our ability to distinguish these different projects when we say,
oh look,
you know,
fake news.
It both sides do it.
Or here's a lie.
Here's Susan Rice's one lie that she told them the last 10 years maybe and got
caught for,
and we have a president who lies every time he picks up his,
you know,
it approaches a Mike or picks up his Twitter.
She had other problems because she had gone on,
I believe on the Sunday morning talk shows after Bengazi was talking points.
Yes.
Yeah.
No,
Susan,
Susan look like she was itching to get caught.
I mean,
whether this is a case of,
yeah.
Uh,
no,
I,
I think your point is very,
very important because I think that you have,
um,
if you have one side that lies all the time,
it's imperative that the other side don't lie at all.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh.
And the line and say,
look,
everybody does it.
It's a tense time for people.
In my line of work because we were so much scrutiny and then we get it wrong.
We really,
you know,
we take a lot of heat,
but when we get it wrong,
I,
I think we're pretty quick to say we got it wrong.
Here's the actual,
here's the truth.
Do you know the Donald Trump Jr said that Cernovich get a Pulitzer.
You're exposing Susan Rice.
Really?
Yeah.
All right.
Yeah,
a bit.
But that's it.
That's why,
that's why this drives me a little crazy because it is not Cernovich is the fact
that,
that this is,
this is [inaudible] to the real world.
Where'd you lead them down?
The Cernovich thing.
You just can't even read them.
Right.
It's,
it's mean a huge lord in front of the kitten.
We're only now discovering the consequences of this.
Let's come back in five years if we're talking about anything that makes any
sense.
Okay.